as we know HTML defines the content of
the page now that we know how to replace
text we can replace placeholders in HTML
with real data
after that we just need to append HTML
strings to start building our resume
let's look inside helper GS which
through the magic of computers we have
over here on this side of the screen it
contains some helper data that your
project will take advantage of because
helper j/s shows up before resume
builder j/s which you can't see but it's
way down here at the bottom of the
screen it will load first and we'll have
access to all the data from helper j/s
when we start writing resume builder j/s
we can see a few string variables here
like HTML mobile HTML email in HTML
twitter each of them has a percent data
percent placeholder here and here and
each of those will be replacing % data %
with our actual data so how are they
going to replace % data % the same way
we replace awesome with fun using the
replace method let's see it let's say I
wanted my properly formatted name to
appear on the page in that case I first
need to create a new variable that
stores HTML with my data I'll save a
variable called formatted name and set
it equal to HTML header name that
replace % data % and pass in a variable
storing my name then I'll pin the
formatted name to the header voila
there's my formatted name very cool